The human race may be more unified by music
than we think.
What if... across the world, specific patterns,
frequencies and rhythms tie to specific human
emotions and applications?
What if music, is… universal?
There is a cross-cultural connection and relation
when it comes to music, where people of all
different backgrounds might have the same
opinions on specific musical notes and songs.
At Harvard University a researcher did a study
of 750 internet users in over 60 countries
and had them listen to portions of songs that
were collected from 86 different small societies
around the world.
They then answered questions on what they
heard.
Each multiple choice option asked what the
purpose of the song may have been for, such
as dancing, soothing a baby, healing illness
etc…
The study showed that despite the fact that
each participant had never heard the music
before, the MAJORITY of them were still able
to relate it to the true purpose of each song.
For example, say there was a song used for
healing in its culture of origin.
This study indicates that even people who
were unfamiliar with the music would likely
guess it was song written for the purpose
of healing!
So, the majority of participants efficiently
chose the correct corresponding mood, emotion
or purpose, related to the song.
One of the main distinctions found in the
study was also that certain songs seem to
oppose each other musically.
For example dance songs were normally faster
and more rhythmically complex, and participants
interpreted these to be happier and well,
more exciting…
Whereas lullabies, were slower, more simple,
and interpreted to be sad and less exciting.
Future research will target participants that
live in smaller-scale societies that may have
never heard music outside of their own culture.
That way we see what THEY have to say regarding
the purposes of different music too.
But music isn’t only found in the human
race, there’s major similarities with humans
and animal songs as well.
Take birds for instance!
One study showed the modal register - a.k.a.
the chest voice - is found in both human speech
and animal song.
In fact, they are surprisingly similar even
though we are very different species.
Can this be a way of showing whether or not
music is truly universal?
What do you guys think?
Hello everyone, like science in your day?
You should subscribe, and speaking of universal,
what sound do other planets make?!
Check Trace's video about the auroras on Jupiter.
One last thing, In that same study, when it
came to detecting love songs, the participants
didn’t do so well in accuracy.
Maybe love is just too complex afterall.
Thanks for watching Seeker!